إن الانتشار الحالي لفيروس كورونا في
الولايات المتحدة مدفوع جزئيًا بالتجمعات الصغيرة
من العائلة الممتدة والأصدقاء
إذا كنت ترغب في استضافة عشاء في الداخل ، فإن
أكثر الأشياء أمانًا هو مطالبة
الجميع بالحجر الصحي لمدة 14 يومًا
ثم إجراء الاختبار قبل ذلك مباشرة
ولكن هذا ليس كذلك  سيكون عمليًا
لمعظم الناس ، ولهذا السبب يجب أن نخطط
لاستضافة
احتفالات الأعياد في الهواء الطلق
، من المرجح أن تتشتت هذه الجسيمات المعدية
قبل أن يتمكن الآخرون من تكاثرها ، وإليك
طريقة للاستضافة بأمان قدر الإمكان
تأكد من تباعد الضيوف من
أسر مختلفة  على بعد ستة أقدام على الأقل ،
لدينا طاولة في المنتصف حيث
وضعنا جميع الأكواب التي
غسلت يدي جيدًا قبل
وضع الأكواب على الطاولة
وسأصبها ، ثم يمكن للضيوف مساعدة
أنفسهم في احتساء المشروبات واحدًا تلو الآخر
دون التجمع.  المشروبات ولكن
بدلاً من ذلك ، أعدها إلى بذورها كما
هو الحال مع الطعام ، يمكنك استخدام
الأطباق والأواني الفضية التي يمكن التخلص منها
إذا كنت ترغب هنا ، فقد قمت بلف
عبوة فردية  مجموعات من السكاكين والشوك والملاعق مقدمًا
بدلاً من أسلوب الأسرة حيث
يساعد الجميع أنفسهم في
صحن الطعام ثم اطلب من الجميع
الحضور بشكل فردي لالتقاط طعامهم
والأواني الفضية وإعادتها إلى
مقاعدهم بالطريقة التي
أرتدي بها قناعًا عندما  التعامل مع الطعام
والشراب ، أطلب أيضًا من الضيوف ارتداء أقنعة
عند وصولهم لأول مرة
خاصة إذا اضطروا للذهاب من خلال
منزلنا للوصول إلى الفناء
عندما نجلس جميعًا على بعد ستة أقدام على الأقل
من بعضنا البعض ،
فلا بأس من خلعنا.  الأقنعة
التي يصعب على الأطفال
الحفاظ على تباعدها الجسدي راقبهم
إذا لم يتمكنوا من القيام بذلك بسهولة لأنهم
يلعبون تتطلب الأقنعة
تحتوي على الكثير من معقمات اليدين واستخدامها بشكل
متكرر ،
أتأكد من أننا نطبقها على الأطفال
كل نصف شهر  ساعة
ماذا لو احتاج الضيوف إلى استخدام الحمام ، خصص
حمامًا واحدًا للضيوف ، اترك النافذة
مفتوحة في الحمام إذا أمكن ،
يجب على الضيوف الذهاب إلى الحمام واحدًا تلو الآخر
مرتديًا الأقنعة ،
ولا ينبغي لأحد التجمع في الداخل للعديد من
الأشخاص ،
فمن المحتمل  عندما يكون الجو باردًا ، اطلب من
الضيوف تجميع
حفرة نار أو يمكن لمصباح حراري أن يساعد أيضًا
ماذا لو هطل المطر أو تساقطت الثلوج
التوقعات مسبقًا بأنك ستعيد تحديد
موعد
ليوم آخر لأولئك الذين ليس
لديهم ساحة يمكنك استضافتها  في حديقة قريبة ،
تأكد من إحضار أقنعة
ومعقم لليدين ،
وأنا أعلم أنه من الصعب ولكن يمكننا تجاوز
هذا الشتاء ،
دعونا نظهر لأحبائنا مدى اهتمامنا
بهم
من خلال توخي الحذر الشديد